okay for those joining the livestream we
are talking about geometry and graphics
functionality and I have an immediate
comment here about this this should be
called tiling shading or something we
can't call it tiling fill pattern we
changed it last time we reviewed us to
fill pattern pattern ceiling okay close
yes okay fine so we're calling it
I see hatching and pattern filling okay
so we have we already looked at these
things here yeah okay so what are we
looking at today the one above doing
non-photorealistic shedding
let's remind ourselves about those ones
there okay so let's go back I'm so
pattern filling right and one of the
things you are
for last time with his strings um that
should say checkerboard it says check
board right now right I'm not entirely
sure that this is the correct base class
of strings to have there um I'm not
either
I don't think they let they look a
little complicated to me to be a base
class so I don't like these I mean that
this is I this should have different
kinds of names I mean it's just no no I
mean it just - do we have anybody from
design on this call could we try to get
somebody please who made these team okay
so let's let's get Tim on this cool sure
just just as an FYI I just saw them this
morning for the first time and and they
need a not a rework so that's the first
prototype I mean we what what's the name
for hatching now what we call should be
a [ __ ] that's not right
be getting Timmy let's see what yes
could you get Tim asked Tim ass look at
what this one say I see also from
pattern feeling I think that's been
named changes here that I'm not today
what's the C also
there aren't any great okay I mean look
at my sources chose yes I'm look at my
sauce is this really strange what in my
sauce I still have watching well maybe I
need to update that vomit update I mean
I should it should have been updated yes
you haven't changed it in a while
watching looked like it was from hacci
know when I it's not something's wrong
with Europe you were hatching my
hatching is fine
yes yeah well then then I don't
understand okay let me come I don't know
who's who's paying here but could you
make send something to Roger and D and
tell him that something went wrong with
the updating on lambda yeah that's weird
cuz I just did an update and it didn't
show and it didn't show much change for
hatching let's take a look
but your hatching is completely
different from my hatch well understand
it's done but so this is completely
wrong
yes maybe the stock eTools is pointing
at the wrong thing let me look at it in
it and a 12o da key tools well maybe we
should look at your version a moment
okay something is very wrong here and we
need to be careful because otherwise my
system will overwrite and spray garbage
all over everything
yeah all right should we look at your
screen then sure okay sure so we looked
at this last time and we added dis
hatching didn't a I'm really I'm really
freaked out by the fact that my version
of hatching isn't that um could could
somebody got hold of Roger and ask him
if he can figure out why that this
happening yeah I just pinged him okay
all right those things we looked at
before these are primer you know various
ways of parameterizing right hatching
these are much more these are not so
controversial I think if you look
to review but this looks like very
mainstream I agree with that kinds of
happy I grew that so um although do we
get Tim here I sounds assumed like I
think you should be joining soon okay um
Tim here well that's beautiful behavior
Roger I mean those that those are way
too - I mean why's that so course that
hatching there can you run that for can
you run that with fine and hatching this
one no I haven't updated of course so be
the same but by default you should have
very fine hatching it should be just
purely like the line the same thickness
fine okay now how do you make gray
hatching what do you mean by that
how do you change the style of hatching
or the hatching is just hatching is just
a rendering of a polygon is that right
yes wait I see okay where any fill
filled area it's not just polygons it
could be a disk to be that's really nice
it's really nice really really nice and
and but wait a minute they kind of want
to have an answer to what you actually
asked how do I make oh yeah you just set
the color obvious no you just set the
color yes and apparent thing you put in
the directive and so on this is really
nice really really nice okay
and so in 3d if i hatch a polygon this
will work yes okay because that will be
something finally we can make the
pictures from the hilbert converse and
geometry book can we all come me not I
can go and get the hilbert combo science
book and look what they look like
you should look so how is hatching
how are you expecting hatching to be
done in 3d are you expecting it to be
done in the plane of the screen or in
the plane of the polygon plane as the
polygons there's an orientation bit
there too
which is complicated but what we do
isn't elevates the line yeah what do you
think what depend of the polygon yes
like if we pick there you know what will
be always on towel like you know I
understand I understand the issue yeah I
understand the issue but I that's a good
question I mean just like we have
surface normals we need surface tangent
somehow right in other words this
defines
I understand the issue I mean we'll have
to have some way of defining it just
gets more complex if you want to
generalize it to something other than
polygons you mean like like NURBS or
something everybody I mean like the
surface atmosphere even well as a matter
of fact it's a well-known theorem in
mathematics you can't comb the hair on a
tennis ball or something right there's
no consistent way to hatch it with you
know with with sort of one-dimensional
things so yes that's totally impossibly
hopelessly it complicated Roger do you
have any thoughts about that
I mean basically it's a homotopy it's
you yeah I I don't know I we I brought
up what you said can we do this in 3d
but yeah there are many things to
resolve before we can sort of for sure
right polygons in 3d seems doable the
spheres and 3d seems mathematically
undoable but but let's come back to the
question okay so then you were gonna
show pattern fill what's the next thing
you're gonna show but you that one came
out correctly and you're on your system
okay and I think these names suck and
I'm not sure I think that they name suck
and I think we need to look at what
should base classes of things be here
I completely agree I think what we
should have is lattice data look at
lattice data which has a bunch tilings
in it I mean I think it's kind of weird
- okay first point the you know I don't
diagrammatic purposes I can't see
anybody using a bunch of these this is
more for decorative purposes and I see I
would say the you know lattice data okay
both um Edie Pegg and Eric weisstein are
both sort of experts in these kinds of
tilings lattices etc sure I mean one
thing that you do for instance if you
think of information visualization you
want to have like a pie slice
distinguished from the next one so a bar
distinguished from the next one those
that like I mean putting some kind of
weird thought and you know how you
distinguish the different clans you know
those British plans yeah these guys
would probably be much more to standard
thing to do there yes absolutely those
are standard kind of drafting type
things those things for pattern filling
are you know literally it's it's it's
like isn't it the case that there's what
are they you know the MacDougall's in
the mug what Evers in Scotland like
distinguished to have Tartans
distinguished by their pattern filling I
don't actually know I must have missed
that but I might be wrong about that
piece of cultural whatever but you know
it's like it's like Flags more or less
right but the fact is that these are
designed to tile nicely that's good
right so these are designs that are nice
they're designed to tile nicely yeah the
tile square that have square tilings
that has that tile is Tim here
yes yeah yeah okay so okay if you bring
up lattice data for a minute I think it
will find here I can when she let me
share again I get yeah I was just
looking at it
what is the lexicon that you're getting
this pattern I mean I've got tons of
these books about patterns you know that
have just like like um you know the Owen
Jones book for instance is a good
example let's let's pull that up in a
second um I think the key concept here
is the wallpaper groups that is a tasty
it also has 2d yeah multiple people on
our live stream is suggesting Penrose
tilings the problem with Penrose tilings
is they don't by definition they don't
tile in square grids just extending on
the plane right and that's what we're
doing here is we're having a square grid
that extends on the plane right so in
fact we by definition we can't I mean
you can use pattern filling you can
design you draw a square with Penrose
tilings and you just keep tiling them oh
no it's not gonna have a sorry no no no
it's never worked this is a periodic
yeah yeah it can never work right and we
didn't set out to build a general tiling
system it's not what it is right so this
this is an example famous example of
like all these different okay that's
more elaborate than we're going for here
but but you know look I mean this is
this is you know something like that
right is a I mean there are many things
that people have designed you know any
one of these kinds of things and as a
matter of fact yeah right i mean it's
it's very unclear what the i mean many
of these are kind of quote
standard patterns well and it should be
pointed out that you know you can do all
of this using texture mapping you know
the you know if you can just you know
get it into an image somehow then you
can text your map it so you know that's
that's always a fallback
yeah I agree I agree and I you know we
have to decide what we're really trying
to do with these patterns here I have to
say I feel like this is not a first-run
type issue the patterns here and I miss
and I think you know I think I want to
give it another crack but I think but
this kind of strengths they shouldn't be
there it doesn't they did they don't
seem to be no I agree with you I agree
with you so it's literally it's still
valuable to have a two-dimensional yeah
you have a two-dimensional object that's
a you know an array of so this pattern
felling thing would allow you to make a
pictogram with a bunch of pictures of
people or something in it is that
correct yes yeah that seems useful I
mean honestly I would have thought this
should map to icon data more than it
should match to any kind of and if you
want to have one of these things somehow
have it in the hatching specification
all right and that this is more for the
pictogram case does that make sense yeah
I kind of suspect we shouldn't have any
strings at this point on this no I agree
I don't think we should except except if
they come from icon data and they're
things like you know people or pies or
something you know I'm saying where
they're each little images that you
repeat and then the big issue is how
often do you repeat those images and how
does it scale okay well I'm saying
somebody did a project of the summer
school this year on pictograms and and
tried to explore some of those issues
like these things because you get these
things while you're making a pictogram
and you want to represent you know
thirty seven and a half thousand people
and you have
a half person Shawn now you know what
I'm saying right
we built a version of this one we did
charts in version 7 it already works
there in a way for football charts and
so on even the 3d ones okay this will be
way more efficient and it can work for
arbitrary fill regions right you can
only do when you do it that that's
slightly lower it's that lower level of
the graphics you know language
implementation right you mean you mean
arbitrary shaped regions yeah I mean not
not just even arbitrary shape is that if
you essentially respect the screen view
if you precise the object we you know we
respect that we don't resize a whole
image it looks basically what you want
is images here if you want this to tile
it's got to be something which is
effectively on the torus topologically
is on a torus right because it wants to
be able to you know the left side has
got to match up with the right side
there and so on that make sense yeah I
mean you don't have to but yes it makes
it nicer right
okay all right Carl on the live stream
is asking about hatching and Geographics
about well so at least the test ID you
can just play it as a style that will
work okay fine
good we should check it does okay let's
continue here alright so now we're going
to look at 3d so what should I look at
there should I look at natural I'll sure
look at something for real there what's
a tuned shading
so we decided last time that we are
going to that these names stop or
shading hatch shading and so on our
standard enough that we can make them
into into actual system symbols is that
right yeah so now if I take for example
something like this
you
so if I take that
why aren't you oh I see
okay that's cool but
get rid of the lighting - accent what's
gonna happen it probably can't Suite 4:3
standard lights which have funky colors
and stuff
too bad not too bad so now if I were to
take um whatever
stipple shading
you
you
it's a really weird effect as I rotate
it but I guess that's what happens with
traders well it was also a choice of not
using the actual geometry normal for
that for efficiency so yeah well it's
really cool I think
well that one looks a bit weird we just
and our colors so accent color stare
would been better
should we set lighting to automatic and
and have it look through whether there
are things with with shaders in it does
that make any sense or
so where is the Weathermen light where
is it good shade oh you say good
chaining red okay I take this color it's
wait I see yeah
Afiya okay so you're saying if I were to
leave it blank there okay is it called -
um color so and and do we have other
name - lighting configurations only one
neutral and standard sorry stan is
probably automatic but if I said neutral
here
what was that really weird autocomplete
you
well now there's no water completed all
oh that's okay yeah
um by the way John this this thing with
the these books symbols wouldn't it be
better if that was an eye since we're
using eye is the thing to get
documentation elsewhere that I every
time I see this I I don't know what it
is
okay can we bring that up in user
assistance or in the UX meeting yeah
yeah I recommend that it's a lighter
version of the eye
okay but anyway that's the that's the
neutral version of that I think these
are really nice okay what do we have to
figure out what these so like for
example in the case of toon shading we
have a color base color in the highlight
color
what are the waiting's here
well say essentially you have three Colo
the dark paths the base color on to
highlight color and you can give them
weight depending of you know how much
surface area of speaking you want to be
covered or motive light so this is an
indexed color scheme yes coming from our
color data this is cool I mean I don't
know well I find that particular one
useful but it's still very cool are all
the indices are all these indexed color
no you have the one which are not and we
subsample it all week led to the base
index color fish when you blend them you
get a continuous family I think sorry so
there again these are these are indexed
colors here okay how do you mean to
discrete color scheme is that a discrete
color scheme I don't know whether it's a
discrete I don't know where the 15 is a
discrete color scheme and color data
yeah all the numbered ones are so how do
I get a continuous one I'd like rainbow
or something yes rainbow by the way
there's no water complete that you
should fix the autocomplete okay how do
I get a woodgrain torus I would gray not
well that's the next future version
where we are going to do the material
those are photorealistic as opposed to
non-photorealistic so we might have a
thing called material shading exactly
yes couldn't have said it twice as good
okay fine
okay let's take a look then at these so
the dark color base color and highlight
color you sure you don't want to put
those in an association or something
you're sure you can just list them out
like that
I mean is that going to be we're not
going to regret the fact that we have a
sixth version another color graphic
directive as simple to specify you don't
that much yeah all right okay fair
enough
so stipple you've got a slightly weird
design thing here with both the
granularity and the color although I
agree that those can be distinguished so
if you say here if I say stipple shading
and then I say rainbow is that going to
work how is that not going to work
what's that gonna do why is there going
off into lala land let's work on
therefore most improvement you just sat
pinked okay so that that should just
generate a message probably because it
couldn't work right because stippling is
a single color isn't it yes but wait but
usually we don't generate message is
thought of doing typesetting but well
then just then it should just pink its
me it would rapidly pink right yes
okay why did this not change I changed
from point one to point O one
what I mean they see that density you
are working on the implementation is not
yet fully done okay fine
what's granularity is granularity
density
yes offered Udacity but it says density
here so it needs to decide whether it
says but it means density or granularity
does density mean what fraction of the
stuff is covered with stipple that shook
that's what it should mean I would
propose that that's what it does mean
that the word granularity doesn't appear
shouldn't appear here where do you see
it oh wait we forgot that part oh yeah
it's also in the last usage message you
know we were changing it everything to
Dodge City I will change a lot okay
point is this working
you
I understand
says parallel lines but I'm not seeing
them well use this so do one of the key
issues here is that you need the actual
normal so the not data you are
generating the object doesn't have
normal and we are not actually computing
them all so why is this not but what is
this I mean so what what are you doing
in this case then so in this case you
know all the normal are considered to be
zero so during the computation that's
why you seems you know we just purely a
so if I say polyhedron data or if I say
uniform polyhedron or well actually why
don't I just say random polyhedron
20 so what am I seeing here why isn't
that has hatched well so those don't
have normal and that's what I mean they
don't have normal polygons no I mean do
the base graphic primitive e.push
doesn't have normal so the current
implementation rely on the fact that you
have we need a vector texture
coordinates I'm sure John and usually
probably talk a little bit more body and
is the one we use right now so if you if
you go to my documentation notebook okay
hold on hold on over the other kind of
shading don't care right yes this is the
one where we actually need it to be able
to use the curvature of the on the
object to actually generate them okay um
and why did that pink magnificent okay
okay let's look at this what the heck is
all that so just some tentative three
names in case we want to add swing
pattern because the base pattern are
just hush lines so you can have the same
type of patterns
what's up women how do I get any of this
you're saying it doesn't work for any of
those it only works for things which
have normals but I don't understand why
random polyhedron for example doesn't
insert normals there is what we are
currently working on you so you sound
like you're in a cave could you please
try and use some method of audio
connection that isn't like a cave
[Music]
we'll pick up a phone
is this better because I'm not at home
right now trying to find a place to -
okay it's not great but it'll do
it's broken it was before okay
I'm currently working on project which
is generating named the vertex texture
coordinates for all the 3d primitives
which makes sense I mean with with
hologram basic primitives and it's the
change is already in currently it's
under review but I just discussed with a
chance to see we should put it in for
the type or not and you're talking about
something else you - this is something
that we hadn't that we want to do
eventually but we haven't the boat
intersect what but intersect that's why
we bought it moving geometry so you
essentially you need the vet actual
coordinate hi God so the way we generate
the hatching but is to - mapping so you
need to know actually how you map to
music touch line on your geometric
object and we do that by reading the
vertex texture coordinate weight and
currently like in this case of handle
yet when we don't have those vectors
Tasha coordinate on how you see saying
for the basic primitive are such you can
automatically add them so the kind of
doesn't want to generate them during
typesetting but for polygons this is
where Stephen will get confused that's
why I didn't want to bring it up okay
I'm glad okay go ahead
no no it will be fine but not it's it's
gonna be we're gonna do one part of this
project that we need right now
eventually what we want to do
roughly what you two said is sort of
named texture mappings like a cube
mapping and a sphere mapping all of
those things
but there's many design corners left to
treat there are many hacks and yeah yeah
there are many design corners and and we
didn't we were sure we didn't have the
bandwidth on this release schedule that
we were not too far behind but right so
what's an example of hatch shading works
so far I haven't found a single one so
look at the example I mean okay so
there's one what the heck is it doing I
mean at shading in horizontal and
vertical random lines but I don't
understand why you think looks texture
coordinates cuz you and then you said
normal and normal we have here but I
don't see vertex texture coordinates
like I said the computation we use the
normal as well as the show coordinator
yes both okay wait I mean how could this
possibly work it doesn't I mean how
could that possibly work there's no way
to have a hilbert curve you know be
consistent on a sphere no no it's not
per se Hilbert is just essentially to
apply that pattern as well as use the
light to give you know that effect okay
so hold on hold on unlike hatching in 2d
this is not a deterministic hatching yes
yes in other words so it's not a
deterministic hatching so it's icy but
so hatch shading is somehow there's oh
it's s stochastic line sampling I don't
know I'm not I'm not wild about this one
seems that muddled right now again why
do you want to put this it I mean you
know if it's experimental enough I
suppose it's okay to have it in here
it's morally not for to see Kissick okay
but it should definitely be considered
experimental for the time being right
don't think it's I I think this is a bit
crazy and again what you were explaining
is there are two things are surface
normals than those vertex texture
coordinates right and the vertex texture
coordinates are a giant can of worms
surface normals don't seem like they're
particularly a kind of worms they just
you know I mean I don't even understand
why why for example for things like a
polyhedron I mean it may be wasteful to
generate them by default yeah but but
can we deduce them we can't really do is
we don't know oh we can for a polyhedron
because it's a graphics because it's a
mesh of some kind I mean we can't do
that for all of them is just you know
dude you work flood the pipeline and
where should it be done in the kernel or
the front end and at what time but we
can pretty much do all that on his watch
is on process I mean okay but in the end
but you know texture mapping is a big
mess and there are many different ways
to do it for complicated surfaces I
think we kind of resolve that tool okay
well that's a very hard problem yeah not
for twelve one for 12 - we expect to
have nice the beginnings of nice
solutions okay fine well so do these are
these expected to work or not and it's
not a trebuchet a trebuchet this is the
thing like a catapult that's a true
shake asset pattern yeah that's right
that's funny actually it's funny yes but
its some level of funny yeah again I
alright okay let's move on okay so what
else should I be looking at here so
you've seen them
have you seen halftone 2 I mean so
that's the five types of an PR shaders
you
is this going to work
should work okay what is the point one
mean does that work it should also be
read a Satine classic it's not in this
case autocomplete is not working what is
that doing is they're actually making
hexagon little hexagons there yes
that's kind of cool I mean this is
somehow for some reason less problematic
I mean than the other ones in terms of
being meaningful yeah that's really nice
that's really nice what are the standard
halftone patterns I mean usually most in
printing most of them are you know just
dots but are there other half turning
patterns that people use I think we can
figure that out either going back to old
mylar sheets yeah but I think we have a
few books that list this is nice this is
nice unlike the other ones where I
wasn't convinced about the you know the
patterns making sense this does make
sense in this case to me at least
looks really nice okay I mean although
the pitch is that what you really want
the
density of shading I don't think you
want that you want a different thing you
want the pitch of shading what is the
how bigger the dots that's not that
that's different there are two different
things there's density in this
granularity and I don't understand why
the density isn't determined by the gray
level the whole thing is controlled by
the light does does it keep out so to
make that effect of that light area you
need smaller dots or smaller squares no
that's not right I'm saying the pitch
between the squares should be variable
did you see what I'm saying look look if
I go to their right I should be able to
make these squares half the size not not
half the distance between squares you
understand what I'm saying
you're talking about the parameter you
used to Prem right what I'm saying is
there are two parameters involved here
one is the density as in the amount of
the area that would be covered by
squares and the other is the pitch
granularity whatever you want to call it
the distance between or alternatively
the DPI value of the squares so to speak
green tragically but you can't do that
because there is a dependency on the
light right okay wait wait wait wait
wait wait this parameter D is
controlling the DPI's yes or no no no no
no no no no no no you're confusing it
okay look all I'm saying is look at
these squares right they have a certain
a certain distance apart yes okay so
what I'm saying is look at the Centers
of those squares and you need a
parameter that determines the distance
between the Centers of those squares and
that parameter needs to be in the same
coordinate system I would think as point
size no but you misunderstand Steven the
way that that's controlled is that you
compute the luminosity from the shader
standard shader pipeline
that luminosity in term control how much
spacing you're gonna have in between so
you can see this effect no you're wrong
look what's controlling the luminosity
is the size of the dots right not the
density of the dots in the sense of dpi
no this is like a highlight effect
there's an independent parameter which
is how finely drawn the thing is what is
the deal we are using us finding is
drawn we don't want to do do or that we
are on because it's obvious hot right I
get it
I get it I've understood that okay so so
what you're saying is for for a neutral
light okay for a given pitch we can call
it D which is in units of you know which
is in point sized units let's say am I
making sense I'm not quite sure what you
mean do you mean 1 over D when you say
pitch I don't know what yes that's what
I mean but but but but look look listen
if these were dots drawn on the screen
right with a certain point size using
our point size primitive right then what
I'm saying is and it's a little
confusing here because I'm saying that
the I'm saying the distance between dots
like line thickness like point size
should be determined in that same
coordinate system
what I'm saying
so you want that rather than D do you
want one over D rather than D no no I
want yes I want the look look I think
that what we should do is if you want
the thing to be finer are you telling me
that right now if I if I make a a
devalue that's larger the things will
get closer together
they don't try to knocks to each other I
don't know how well is this him how
completely we see that permutation of DV
we're trying to figure out it should be
do does each other granularity well okay
fine so I mean 0.5 to 3 or something
yeah okay so okay so I think this is the
wrong way around I think it's the wrong
way around I think this D should be in
the same units as point size did you get
what I'm saying
remember how point size works right
point is a relative thing
mean absolute point size it could be
absolute point size yes oh well it could
be either one it could be I don't know
exactly which one will be more
convenient it could be absolute point
size but I think it should be in point
size I think it's in I don't think you
want this no you do not want this one
over thing I don't understand how the
one over thing could be useful I mean if
you have it be in conceptual pixels or
something and which points when you give
it that point size which one do you
think that you setting up the one where
it's you know the highlighted ones or
the ones I'm saying no no Roger I'm
using point size to define distances I'm
not using point size to talk about the
size of points you go what I'm saying
I'm using sewing sizes merely but then
it that's a different rendering effects
because you want to keep the same sizes
of dots let's say just varying the
distance someone no no no no no I'm
talking about the exact same thing
you're talking about here
okay there is a distance between dots
whatever it is right and it's constant
yes and I'm trying to decide in what
units you specify the distance between
dots right again so possible units are
pixels right scaled units sure okay or
some kind of weird
inverse units which is what you're doing
right now which i think is wrong right
so what I'm saying is what I suggest the
advantage you know like intensity it
says how many how much stuff per area
how many events per area its yes right
but I mean you can also think of it okay
let's look at what you're doing for
hatching what are you doing for hatching
what is the parameter mean there I
thought the parameter was a non 1-over
parameter in the case of of hatching
isn't it the hatch Shea
the smaller the number the closer the
lines in hatching correct do you look at
can you bring it up no because my one
was broken no death hatching yes that
hatching 2d hatching the smaller the
number the closer the lines correct I
think the smaller the number don't tell
me that as well
no no hatching do be do number D theta
there was more the angle of the lines
right there's also a a fineness of lines
yeah parallel lines the gaps of absolute
thickness are yes thank you that's
exactly what I'm saying should happen in
the case of this half toning thing you
know you can say gaps of thickness but
actually don't mean gaps of thickness
you mean the inter line spacing is are
right yeah I think this do not mean gaps
because the gaps are determined by how
much what the density of lines as in the
fraction of area that's covered by lines
is and what I assume is the case is that
given a higher great you know a great
level that is close to the black that
you're making the lines thicker is that
true in one case the line you mean for
hatching or for the hatching for
hatching
perhaps you are determining the gray
level to be the average density of ink
I'm assuming otherwise how could it
possibly work it's true are you ignoring
when you have hatching oh I see I'm
sorry no no never mind never mind ignore
that comment you're determining the gray
over the ink that is put into the
hatched lines but then you have another
parameter with hatching which is the the
thickness of the lines right well
justified with what's that
yes there is a thickness of the line
which is a parameter into hatching okay
and but but then so you've got two
parameters you've got the inter line
spacing which is probably what you
should call it and you've got the
thickness of each line as well as the
angle of the lines right yeah but I'm
looking at the spec now it really sort
of specs they're the things that we
don't have the entire life spaces it's
more like dashing it's actually like a
dashing specialization still it's very
it's exactly like a dashing dashing so
we got it from there until how does
dashing work you give this you see how
much is black certain distance how much
is empty how much is black how much is
empty okay but there's also there's also
a length of the dashing yes yeah that's
what I was saying how much of the length
of the - II know but there's a way of
specifying the absolute dashing right
there's that there's a nother thing
right if I want dotted lines I do that
by saying there's an absolute dashing
here right that says throw them with
successive segments to be of these
absolute lengths right but that's
absolute dashing right so that's there's
- this dashing in absolute dashing yes
but so what what do we want to do with
hatching you've got to be able to draw
very fine lines very fine closely spaced
lines how do you do that okay
illustration really shows it all okay
Steve go ahead look at this illustration
here r1 r2 because it at r1 is I don't
think the r2 is the right number I think
the r2 should be the inter line spacing
between the Centers of the lines but I
see but you're thinking about it like
dashing well that's not completely silly
I'm sorry I'm I take it back so I'm
completely silly so but those numbers
are specified r1 and r2 it they
specified an absolute pixels or what
yeah the fun was to be absolute pixels
okay so it's the analog of absolute
dashing correct yes so the identity the
theory says sure right okay so the
theorem theorem is you go with if you if
you're surfing the waves so to speak
here what you see is exactly if you take
a one dimensional slice through these
waves you will see exactly a dashing
pattern an absolute dashing pattern
correct yes yes okay that makes sense so
we should we should bring out that
identity then okay so having seen that
in in 3d we also have dashing right
which is stochastic this one is termina
sztyc no that no but the half toning
which we could also have okay so how do
we get half toning in 2d like Wall
Street Journal photo rendering e-type
thing you know what I'm saying that that
the stipple pattern how do we get that
in 2d for me that was more specialized
make sure show he's more decimal an
image that thing but it isn't I mean
people do that in 2d look at what what's
the ROI whatever his name Lichtenstein
whatever it is that artist right there
you know
you look at any I mean that's how
printing works to that what I mean that
usually the base object behind I have
seen is you know people use an image not
they say geometric like somebody do that
on a polygon or a triangle you're right
it is usually an imagined but but that's
a so what are you saying that that it
should be an image force on to do that
effect and we I believe in one of the
marketing page we actually did which one
because we why is that explain to me why
in 3d I see because it's more image like
you claim to do 3d rendering um okay
okay but let's come back to how the half
toning pitch is specified right because
your density I do not believe in your
inverse density thing I think that's
gonna be I mean would you no no I mean
in the case of of dashing you're giving
absolute point sizes so why aren't you
doing the same thing for the why isn't
the D parameter in the halftone shading
exactly the same thing that is well
what was our one I'm sorry in that
previous picture can you show me again
what was our one what was the default if
you give only one parameter one r-value
I don't think that's right I just don't
think that's right you give one value we
assume that is essentially do the white
space the gap so the line have a
thickness of zero so R 1 is 0 and R is
equal to the value you are giving and I
can't be 0 right no it's not we're the
predecessor we don't say that it's zero
so if you give it t Takuma ah you assume
that you want to say that the gap is
size ah no but Charles is there a main
effect is how thick of the lines that's
the main thing you know you either want
very usually you want pretty thin lines
right wait so are you saying the default
is zero thickness effectively you know
zero thickness lines won't work if you
print them on a photo typesetter you
know they'll just disappear zero
thickness lines might work on screens
but they won't work on sufficiently high
resolution things well when I see the
thickness is just essentially what you
do with our normal line if you do a
classic of a line what if I don't think
that's right that's much thicker than
you want here what you we do for a line
is vastly thicker than we want in in
this hashing pattern hatching pattern
wants do we have okay have you shown
this to people from the design group no
we haven't
finished implementation on lists No okay
alright so I'm gonna tell you I think
what you want to do here is first of all
the default line thickness should be
considerably thinner than a standard
line maybe a quarter the size I'm not
sure okay
second point is I the question of how
filled in it is I don't know whether the
right parameter is to change I think it
probably is to change the inter line
distance not that are two parameter to
go from the set I think it should be
center of line to the center line I
don't think this is right okay anyway
look you can I mean maybe it will I'm
sorry you're saying treat it like okay
if you give one parameter there in the
case of dashing that parameter is equal
- lengths
okay so absolute dashing a single
parameter is equal length that is
density one half okay but that's not
going to look right here am I making
sense yes so I don't know whether this
dashing model is gonna work I think you
need to bring this back for another
discussion okay and with respect to the
other I strongly think that you need a
parameter which is I would I would
recommend using an inter feature
distance parameter that is in points
okay by inter feature distance I mean
inter line in this case into dots in the
case of half turning that makes sense
yes and um okay so fine all right now
where were we before
okay can you unsure
um okay what were we talking about
before that so we've gone over the
halftone the case this hat shading I
find a bit unconvincing although it's
kind of a cool effect okay what else do
we need to talk about we've got a number
of comments on the live stream let's
take a look at what some of these are um
Oh somebody agreeing with me about the
eye icon rather than the book thank you
um um okay let's see
um
okay so I'm assuming by the way that if
you color the hatching it will just take
on the color that you give it yeah you
will
um okay and there's the question of do
you wants salmon on a live stream is
asking about red blue checkerboards what
is the so in principle there are two
colors associated with the hatched area
right the background color and the
foreground color correct
are we parameterizing those okay in a
hatched pattern there are two colors the
colors of the spaces and the colors of
the lines
right in in 2d case chose 2d case yes
imagine that you have a polygon where
you want ugly you know
yellow stripes on a blue background
right how do you get that
in your hatching specification I didn't
see a background color I think you need
it like in face form get what I'm saying
in face form you have what yes so that
was actually something that no internal
meeting so why do you want to specify
that we can pass it to the face form but
we don't yet have some way to specify it
explicitly no but but but but no that I
don't understand if you say red and then
you give a polygon that is hatched right
yes that red is is flowing through to
the foreground color of the hatching not
the background color of the polygon yes
I would recommend that in the hatching
itself you allow a possibility of giving
basically the on off colors I mean it's
looking less and less like dashing
honestly so we I think you need to add
another argument that gives the
background color let the folks on just a
back home know both of them but like you
got at it oh no no I'm sorry I'm wrong
I'm wrong I'm wrong I'm wrong I'm wrong
I'm wrong you're right
you need somewhere to specify the
background color and I don't think you
can do it in face form because face form
I mean unless you have some extra hack
in face form but somehow okay I don't
object to it being in face form if you
can figure out a good way to do it okay
but right now face form doesn't specify
that it only specifies front and back
faces right yes it doesn't seem like the
right place I mean if there was a
background option for hatching that
might make sense but you're trying to
avoid options in graphics primitives so
I have a think about it I don't know
okay
and do we think the default background
is what none the default background is
nothing yeah it's and yeah so that
meaning kids where you quit you put it
you know you put back on their head then
you have you head back home
exactly right polygon itself
interestingly I should say if you
overlap two polygons with different
potentially different hatching at
different angles
right now right and you also will want
the possibility of having you know a
white background in fact that's a good
reason to have that right in the
hatching directive because you want to
say no don't make it transparent make it
white so that when two polygons overlap
they won't look stupid right otherwise
you're gonna get them what a giant
soirée effect right okay Carl is saying
he wants a pattern data function that's
amusing well we should probably put some
of those in the in the data repository
actually we should probably have a
repository of such patterns somebody
should make Owen Jones's book from the
eighteen whenever it was make it
computable it's a good good idea but I
will make a note of that and my
collection of student projects for next
year's summer programs um
um
[Music]
okay
all right let's see questions here
you
single color patterns right okay Carl
not to mix up telling algebra isn't
Tunes shading normally known as cell
shading
is also known as yeah but cel-shading we
just completely obscure as a name for us
given all the other uses of cell where
animals don't think it's the most
commonly used name but we typically list
um and you see it says there under two
shading toon shading is also known as
cell shading fine but I think for us
tune is a nice unique name um
several questions here about shadows
well read one of them but I mean the
point is that we're not doing shadows at
this point I know we're not yeah they're
asking when are we going to do shadows I
see good question I think I think my
shadow is fundamentally hard I mean do
they require a tracing or a shadows from
now not ray tracing but they're global
so the it's a global shading operation
kind of like transparencies so you need
to look at the whole graphic scene as
opposed to locally which means they're
much more expensive and we think it's
important I think it can be important I
think it's more important to more
complex the graphics is that you have
because they give better data cute yeah
it's not only poor
but it's not as important if our main
thing is sort of plotting 3d surfaces
and stuff right
okay uh Shea does not look at local
geometry as they they do that was well
these shaders don't look at local
geometry right these shaders are just
right they're just flat on the screen I
have their local because they're based
on luminosity and luminosity gets
computed through local shaders did
Charlie yes okay do you understand I
think so yeah
so comment
Boateng custom full shaders on GPUs
would be great I believe that's exactly
what's coming no I
I mean maybe we'll do that one day but
it's it's seriously hard to do that
these guys interact with our rendering
loop and local variables used on the GPU
seriously you know and one of the other
issues is we're having to implement this
in three different rendering systems
which have three different shading
languages just for good measure right
okay
is there a function that takes
returns a half-turn version of it I
believe there is under him there is if
there isn't no well think that there is
there's stippling and there might be a
halftone affect image effects has these
right ah comment the for annoy taking
look nice a call for name parameters I
hope we will not need that here
um
oh gosh that's an important that's an
interesting point
what if you want a multicolored you know
like the French flag repeated in your
hatching pattern well you just give it
locally and it repeats it with pattern
darling you just like graphic
yeah pattern you know paper but but
hatching won't do that hatching oh is
distinctly a single color on a
background if you want the French flag
you have to have you have to use pattern
filling yes
you
I earn comments that they're expired
Lockheed Martin patents from their
flight simulation division that have
very fast cheap shading schemes that are
often used in video games it's
interesting fact they say that locking
what but there are well that Devon can
pass it on okay yeah they're um okay
let's keep going a bit we're rather late
here but let's keep going because we've
only managed to get through one area
here okay so this has to come back for
us a little bit more discussion yeah
okay it's great it's really great really
really cool really like it okay two key
properties of meshes topology and
metrics mesh connectivity graph I
believe you dissection already I think I
did - yeah yeah this was nice
whatwhat else do we have to look at here
nothing I like Jason mesh ourselves okay
fine so this is done okay
okay Oh as opposed to geo area that's
the projected area is that correct yes
yes can we look at this before we did
quickly yes okay so what are the units
of that so currently we don't have a new
unit
no butBut Jose I mean other other grid
coordinates but so the Mercator
projection of the earth for example in
grid coordinates so this would be in
projected square degrees okay but like
if it's the US you know if it's the
Kansas State net you know state grid
system or something what are we doing
there it's default reference model and
you can change it how can you change it
by specifying the projection with the
reference model parameters so for
example if you do the projection data of
Mercator you see the reference molar 180
divided by PI that's our way of saying
I'm using degrees if that was one we
will be using radians we have a symbol
called reference model no reference
model is world projections used since
version 7 we did a symbol or is it a
string it's this thing do we support
this as an association as well yeah okay
fine so that's what whatever reference
model it's a term of art and geodesy
right that represents the transformation
of those things okay so fine any units
we want okay that's fine
okay on the globe which geo area right
okay
oh good okay um
okay well Matt ah Cohen from Karl
speaking projections would be really
great to see
bps g-code support in geo projection
data what is that yes we are having that
in and it's a model of data related to
historical and currently used atoms huh
okay I never heard of it yes ESG means
European petroleum survey group they
have collected this table of it
Wow okay set what a lot of this servers
were using yes servers use these epsg
notation I mean it has been absurd about
this other association IO GP and but
they keep the name so this is a boatload
of other projections that we haven't had
previously who had a lot of projections
no this is not so much about projections
this is about datums and the numbers
that relate some to others it's about
transformations how does that show up in
our but does that appear in jail
projection data for us or something else
this IPS decodes and returned some
numbers that say right Ethan is
complaining that d3 is faster for geo
stuff because WebGL earth is easy to
deploy well that's the point of our
dynamic geographic stuff which hopefully
will similarly be fast on websites um
and I think in general we just upgraded
our geo servers so things should be
getting considerably faster fragment
shaders on WebGL should make cloud
implementation fast don't know um okay
so let's keep going here um
[Music]
oh my gosh there apparently is a Carla's
saying that he's he's very pleased about
the epsg support and there are many
local protections like the Irish
transverse Mercator projection which I
admit it's not one that I've heard of um
okay different projections they are the
same projection it's just that they
choose values that are adapted to their
region I feel these parameters no I
understand I understand that that they
like you know right there just nicely
centered and arranged but we will have
all of those names then in our people
refer to these with codes okay fine okay
all right web regions search and then
okay so this is just bug fixes okay new
formats I don't know what that is
FBX you acts maybe 20 times to support
that okay all right okay okay whatever
okay embarrassing um the
okay and DCCC means digital content
creation okay so these are things like
Maya softy Marsh
alright so that's why I was asking for
it yes yes because that's the modern way
that those things are exporting stuff
yes yeah okay that's that's the point
okay
web region search last thing to look at
here which apparently you guys
continued to discuss and I just learned
it got renamed to web geometry recent
web geometry search from your guys
continued discussion okay well okay so
if I say something like tourists not but
the only thing disses will return our
region so Web Audio search returns audio
web image search returns image but web
geometry search returns regions only
regions no other kinds of geometry what
are the kinds of geometry other well I
don't know what what's in synthetic
geometry are not regions okay so then I
could say copy that
and then I paste it that is a very funky
interface if I'd copy defied selected
multiple ones it would have made a list
yes it's an interesting interface but we
don't use that anywhere else how else
can you gonna pick no I think it's
interesting but you're not doing that an
audio search are you we want to do okay
it's fine the Doge is more the player
why there's also that aspect no I
understand that but at least you see the
waveform there so question um I mean we
were supposed to have a sort of summit
meeting about end product browsing for
some reason that didn't happen right
relevant to the system model or examples
relevant to other things could we I mean
Devin I think that's something for you
you make sure that that gets followed up
okay so let's take a look at this thing
here so what is this how do I get out
something reasonable here
Oh sauce data of this
Wow that's pretty cool so if I say
something like come r2d2 that's such a
bad example let's no no no let me let me
try something better
no apparently there are some how about
this
sore skull or something good okay so
then I picked the one that I think looks
most promising so that's probably that
one and I press copy and then I say
resource data of that so is there a good
reason why you're not showing the
thumbnail in this resource object thing
oh my god yeah I mean Bob issue to
change that okay so we are going to need
thumbnails there for other purposes so I
think you should react the question okay
okay so what do I get to do with this
millennium fawlcon
easy fullness rage on what can i okay so
if I say augmented polygons or something
can I could I augment it why is there
aught mented data backtick why is that
displayed in the autocomplete okay this
would be a question for John if John is
still with us yeah I think that okay
fine how do I just do something bizarre
with this Millennium Falcon
I try to see it compute something
Charles to form it in some way convex
hull okay lets him do shrink wrap a
Millennium Falcon oh you can yes it yeah
that's me to work okay
nice okay okay hold on a second we got a
number of questions here people like a
texture in 3d graphics how would I use
the epsg code or back to that is it geo
projection Aero epsg : 21:57 even though
it's not a projection what's the answer
to that Jose so you can place the code
in any place you can place a projection
or a datum and then the system will know
how to extract from the code all the
data is near it okay so it's just geo
projection arrow some representation of
the code okay fair enough okay next
question being asked here is what about
importing from I just sand Paris solid
that's
because they have all kinds of weird
primitives in them right what about
exporting to I just parasol in step
isn't plan not for this version okay
asking it much very interesting to be
able to use what language is a slicer
for 3d printing that would spit out
g-code yeah I mean the number of people
who've written g-code interpreters for
both language is ridiculously large and
arguably we should have a standard
g-code thing but apparently there were
like millions of versions of g-code
isn't that right Roger Charles anybody
want to comment on I saw hold on I think
you said to one to visualize g-code is
totally different from generating g-code
um an important key they don't think
that we I mean we can do that that I
wrote one it's you know takes about 30
minutes to write one but I don't think
we should write the slicer cuz nobody
can sell a printer without this no no I
agree I agree there's no point and
there's a bunch of hardware oriented
things for each and every printer that
needs to be specified there I don't
think we want to be in the business of
doing that
right
how do i how do i slice the Millennium
Falcon in half so to speak how do I look
at half of it can I do a graphics
graphics 3d um well you were getting an
image 3d toolbar there were you not yes
no touch so oooo mesh okay sorry
then you can't do graphic Tweedy under
use a triple cleans if I take two what
what happens if I say geometric union or
region union of and how do i do of like
one of these guys of that is it does
take a list or not a list you should
work with on without at least
that was boring maybe I need a bigger
number oh no I have two tickets you have
two oh look at that whatever those
things are yeah wowee look at that thing
works perfectly so so in principle if I
wanted to I'm sorry I'm playing here and
I shouldn't be but if I wanted to I
could make a table of Translate of that
thing comma n zero zero so I could make
like a Millennium Falcon caterpillar
millipede whatever it is so that's a
translate of that thing and I'm making a
table and goes
let's say 0 to 300 and steps of 40 that
going to work
look at that that almost deserves to be
tweeted on on the grounds of channel
funkiness well well that's cool well
done yeah okay good um okay should be
able to apply a material yeah we know
but that's future
what about the dot blend file format so
by the way presumably for this I can
perfectly well say graphics 3d of um
let's say um halftone shading of that is
that true yes Wow
why is it color is the light to default
light of our 44 light colored if you
light so you should be do lighting no
accent okay well I don't need to right
now
it's cool enough as it is um okay what
about the top blend format file format
it's not been one let's come up for
analysts where who use lender blender oh
wow well probably why we don't do
exporting and work on the DCC or such
system we probably will end up doing
that so fair enough um okay I think
that's probably
everything I do feel like tweeting this
thing should I tweet this thing maybe
not
it's kind of funny um well I'll save
this file I think about it later
I could tweet it right now from the
language but let's not do that okay this
suggestion okay
you
you
I think it would look better in a
different color sorry I've just um all
right we'll we'll tweet this um okay um
how various people are suggesting that I
tweet this alright I will tweet this um
okay
I don't think I'll do it right now from
the language um okay good anything else
we need to cover here all right God
let's take a screen capture and um okay
thanks a lot guys thank you to people on
the livestream a lot of very useful
comments much appreciated and see you
next time by the way if people are
wondering I believe the next live stream
is actually gonna be in several days
because I have to go away tomorrow
um and then next week is our technology
conference with perhaps some
live-streaming and lots of good in
person stuff okay talk to you soon bye